[Music]
what i tell you
there's that truck sticking out of the
school right there
come on
uh
hmm
ellie run run
[Applause]
well that was easier than i thought it'd
be
they must be holed up somewhere else
well let's not test our luck how do we
get inside
someone left a ladder on the bus
here get me up there and i'll drop it to
you
don't get killed up there thanks bill
[Applause]
we're okay we just need to get to the
hood of the truck
[ __ ] you hear that they're coming move
it kid
all right
we're gonna get in quick we're gonna get
the battery we're gonna get the hell out
of
they're piling on this here over here
come on
joel we gotta weigh in
[Applause]
grab this
please tell me you're done
tim what
[ __ ] empty guys phil where to uh bill
where anywhere but here you play the
whole ass come on
[Music]
let's um
we'll sneak out the back
you two follow me
i'll get this out of here
get my guests
to your right
[Applause]
[Applause]
down the hall i bet we can cut through
those classrooms
there's a way through
gotta get past those guys
ah
[Applause]
looks like there's a path down this
hallway
[Music]
that was [ __ ] close
help me open this
all right ready
come on [ __ ]
there's more on the way
barricade the doors
this ain't gonna hold up for long
[Music]
stay away from it
[Music]
[Music]